hello everyone and welcome to the speed
Chess Championship quarterfinals where
we have a very nice game between Magnus
Carlton and Fabiano caruana pretty much
all of the games from all the time
formats are great this is the one I
chose as it's uh it features all the all
the things that we enjoy and the two
Rivals you all know them uh the former
oh well still the the reigning World
Series champion for Magnus Carlsen and
the World Chess Championship Challenger
from 2018 uh Fabiano challenge Magnus
for the title uh in in London in 2018 he
was unable to take the title away from
Agnes but he did draw all the classical
games and then only succumbed at the
magnus's uh wrath in the in the rapid
section of the event but now this is
speed chess uh for those of you who may
not know first we have an hour and a
half of five plus one then 60 Minutes of
three plus one and then 30 minutes of
one plus one uh sort of a slower bullet
if you will and uh uh yesterday as the
Croatia was also playing Guardian
started playing one hour before the
Argentina Croatia match so I was able to
upload that one game but this is what I
uh posted on on Twitter I asked who wins
today and uh 32 percent of people said
Croatian Magnus win five percent said
Croatia and Fabi win 59 of people said
Argentina and Magnus win and four
percent of people said Argentina and
Fabi uh win out of the 4316 people who
voted and uh do people know their stuff
or what but okay let's uh check out the
game as it's really an awesome one and
then we're gonna discuss everything that
happened in the match so Magnus has the
wide pieces and he opens with E4 we have
C5 by Fabi going for the Sicilian
Defense Knight to F3 E6 and now C3 going
for the all up in variation not going
for uh a central breakthrough with D4
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E5 Knight
the D5 and the bishop the C for D4 is
still more popular but the bishop the C4
is what Magnus goes for D6 and now uh
Pawn to D4 we have captors captures
Bishop to E7 and both players Castle so
castles castles Rook to E1 and now there
are some games where Knight the C6 was
played also B6 is a known also uh uh D
captures and E5 is a known move but Fabi
plays Knight to D7 and it is now as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how Magnus plays this
he goes e captures on D6 uh Bishop
captures and Knight the C3 now Fabi
trades Knight captures B captures and
now Pawn to B6 and okay Fabi already has
a beautiful dark Square bishop and this
diagonal he's gonna put this bush pun B7
control this diagonal and that uh could
very very well uh be a a bishop pair
from hell so Knight the G5 now Magnus
with some ideas of maybe checkmating the
black king So Knights to F6 and now
Queen to F3 stopping Bishop to B7 but
only for the moment we have Queen to C7
a beautiful move by Fabi uh if you go
for for Rook to B8 then Bishop to D3 and
then uh White will white will have a lot
of counter play but after Queen the C7
Fabi offers an entire Rook but it would
be a mistake to capture it if Magnus
captures The Rook then there's Bishop to
B7 you don't even go after the bishop
here you play Bishop to B7 and after
Queen captures an A7 now you play Bishop
captures on H2 with check Force the
white king to a light square and after
King to H1 or King to F1 doesn't really
matter just Bishop captures and G2 with
check and now the queen of course will
hang but it goes even deeper than that
King characters in G2 Queen captures an
A7 and now if you could capture an H2 it
wouldn't be all that all that bad you
would have you would have a significant
compensation but after King captures on
H2 there's Queen to C7 check picking up
the bishop and C4 so once the king moves
Queen captures on C4 and now as you can
see you would have a
sorry about that a rook and a bishop for
a queen which is not really great
compensation it could be but it's just
not in this position so I'm for Queen to
see seven Magnus goes back Bishop to D3
He doesn't want to do it but uh I mean
there's a there's nothing better and of
course you cannot capture on C3
otherwise Bishop captures with Chuck
picks up the black queen so just Bishop
to B7 attacks the queen queen H3 now
with a triple attack on the H7 pawn and
of course Pawn to H6 we have Knight to
E4 and here Fabi trades captures
captures captures and captures an e for
the C3 Pawn still nicely that's a weird
arrow and the C3 Pawn still nicely
defended and Rook a to C8 putting
pressure on the C3 pawn bishop to D2
defending and now Queen to C4 uh just
activating the Queen the queen will be
uh controlling uh a lot more Square from
here and also if you move the Rook then
the A2 Pawn will hang so Pawn to A4 King
to H7 and now Queen to F3 by Magnus we
have Queen D5 now not allowing The Rook
to move and Magnus has to figure out how
to play this because he really didn't
get all that much out of the opening but
so far he still hasn't lost the game he
went through the entire five plus one
section without losing the game and
still uh without a scratch and he plays
G3 he wants to play King to G2 move the
rook and offer a queen trade to Fabi so
Rook the C7 Fabi goes for for a nice
Rook doubling on the C file King to G2
with Rook F to C8 and now Rook a a rook
uh sorry Rook back back to E1 offering a
queen trade which Fabi goes for Queen
captures King captures and now King to
G6 Fabi also activates his Rook uh
Magnus goes Rook e to B1 preparing A5 as
um well the uh there's an A and B Pawn
for Fabi and there's only an a pawn for
Magnus so he wants to mess up that pawn
structure we have Pawn to E5 by Fabi A5
and now B e captures an A5 we have Rook
captures on A5 and now e captures on D4
we have C characters on D4 and now Rook
to D7 preparing to go after that D4 pawn
bishop to E3 and now Bush to E7 and here
Magnus played H4 and it's still a
position that could could really go uh
either way uh that there's a pass the D
Pawn for Magnus there's a past a pawn
for Fabi uh but here Fabi played Ponte
H5 and this is the first real chance
Magnus gets uh in the game uh he uh
because he really didn't get all that
much out of the opening so what did Fabi
Miss with playing Ponte H5 feel free to
pause the video and try to exploit this
inaccuracy well I'll give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
this Pawn or this Pawn will uh be
removed from the board and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook beat the B5 uh the the pawn on
H5 cannot be defended and it really
doesn't matter what what you play uh for
example if you play Rook to h8 and
that's pretty much the only way to
defend it uh you're just gonna play Rook
to A6 with check and now after this is
blocked now you're gonna play Rook to G5
with check King to F7 and not Rook G to
A5 and now you cannot defend both the H5
pawn and the A7 Pawn uh The Rook is just
unable to defend both of them so you
would lose one of those pawns so instead
after Rook beat the b55 he played Bishop
to d8 he said all right at least you
have to move the Rook but now Rook the
A6 check Bishop to B6 nicely blocking
and adding another Defender to the A7
Pawn but now Rook the G5 with check and
now the problem is Fabi cannot go to H6
because if you go to H6 you are running
into some very nasty discoveries here
Rook to D5 check for example would win a
full Rook so far we had to play King to
H7 and now just Rook captures and H5
Magnus grabs uh a Pawn King to G8 with
Rook to A4 now uh as this uh this Pawn
was hanging so Magnus defends it Rook to
C3 and now Magnus plays King to G2 and
it was a it was an incredibly sharp
position even though it's an end game
and the Magnus should have played King
to e for instead of King to G2 he wanted
to unpin but with the King and E4
instead of on G2 you control the D3
square and the Fabi really wants to put
the Rook on D3 they have a triple attack
against the the D4 Pawn but this is uh
three plus one blitz so you cannot see
everything Rook to D3 by Fabi taking
advantage of this right away and now
Rook the C4 trying to trick uh Fabian to
capture during the pawn because if he
does it now just Rook to see it check
and this is Checkmate and what Fabi
should do here is just move the Rook
back and the next move capture this Pawn
that's how you do it but Fabi played G6
and this gives Magnus all sorts of ideas
on how to harass that black king he
plays Rook to C8 with check King G7 and
now Rook H to h8 Preparing Bishop to G5
which will control F6 and H6 and then
some checkmating ideas with Rook seat
the G8 come to mind and here we have
King the F6 uh the problem is if you go
for Bishop characters on D for now while
you could do it uh look at this bishop
to G5 like we said now you have to play
F6 to prevent Checkmate but now Bishop
H6 check King to F7 and The Rook to H7
check King to E6 guarding the D7 square
and now Rook to E8 with check King D6
now Bishop to F4 check and after you
block this with Bishop to E5 now Bishop
captures Pawn captors and Rook captures
on D7 King captures and Rook captures on
E5 uh you're up only one Pawn but this
is a weak Pawn this is a weak pawn and
the white pawns are much too strong the
king cannot cross the E file uh so this
is uh too easy to win for white so
that's the problem with capturing the
pawn now so far he goes King to F6 but
now Rook C to E8 cutting off the king
from the e file King to F5 Fabi is now
without uh any any other option he has
to go active with the King and now Pawn
to F3 by Magnus because both of them
were in severe time control I will just
show a missed mate in it's a force
mating 9 but of course much sooner
because you would have to play Silly
moves in order for it to be mating nine
uh Rook the E5 check you force the king
back Bishop G5 check you force the king
back and now Rook E38 and now there is
no F6 and there is no move you can play
you are just getting checkmated if F6
now doesn't really matter just the best
page six check King to F7 and not as the
Rook is on the E file this will be
Checkmate also one of the reasons why
Magnus put the Rook to the E file but he
missed it he played Ponte F3 and now he
allows this exchange sacrifice which
keeps Fabi in the game but only for a
little bit Rook captures an E3 was
played Rook captures on D4 and now Pawn
to G4 check King to F4 and The Rook to
E2 stopping any checks Here pawn to F5
by Fabi Magnus trades captures captures
and now a spectacular move by Magnus
Rook to f8 threatening the nastiest of
ideas and Fabi misses it but even if he
didn't there's really not all that much
to play for uh with white here with
black here you're down the exchange and
also the past H1 is just too strong Fabi
played Rook to D3 he wanted to win the
F3 Pawn but now of course you will see
it Magnus delivered it it is uh truly a
spectacular move uh Rook to e48
beautiful mating one and of course uh
this uh means that he also won the game
so really a wild game and every game
from this match was wild if you really
want I I could show another one uh
because they were they were just brutal
it was uh not uh and not easy to watch
Fabi struggle like this because in the
end out of the 26 games that were played
Fabi only got uh Four Points yeah so the
the final result is uh uh 20 22 to 4 in
magnus's favor and those four points did
not um uh you know come into existence
by Fabi winning games it was actually a
to draw so Fabi did not win a single
game and the Magnus at some point even
got 10 wins in row which in Chester the
terminology is called adoption if
someone doesn't know so if you adopt
someone that means you you have defeated
them 10 times in a row and usually you
will see this on leeches orange
chills.com if someone plays against the
weaker opponent then they will win uh 10
times in a row against them but against
a former World Series Championship
Challenger winning 10 games in a row
that's uh I don't know that's pretty
much a Magnus exclusive territory I
don't know if anyone else could could
pull that off uh but yeah Magnus wins
the five plus one section with a result
of six to two he wins the three plus one
with a result of seven to one and he
wins the bullet section uh with a result
of nine to one so absolutely crushing it
in in every time format and for those of
you who are interested here uh is what's
going on in the speeches Championship so
uh Nakamura defeated uh Levon and he
will be facing nihal sarin in the
semi-finals who has defeated Ding lyron
and Nakamura defeated Levon pretty badly
15 and a half to eight and a half uh
nihal defeated the ding also with a
pretty fine score with 17 uh to nine but
Magnus crushed carwana 22-4 which is uh
uh I believe so far uh unseen in the
speed Chess Championship history I
believe I could be wrong but I've never
seen this so we'll see what happens in
the Wesley store versus Maxima Sherlock
quarterfinal who will face Magnus in the
semi-final and who will uh in the end
emerge a Victorious to play for
everything in the final will we get
another Magnus versus Hikaru match or
will it be something else uh we'll have
to wait and see so uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh brilliant
stuff by Magnus as usual like I said a
few once he returned home and he started
playing well uh he just started playing
much much better than he played for for
the past like three months for some
reason uh but yeah really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Logan
though but Jeff Graves friends is there
Benjamin Richie and Timothy Rosen for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing uh to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and I
just realized I haven't uh dated my
interface for some reason even though
it's the same one from from the previous
game I just messed up the donations and
the the quote above the board so there
you have it uh
what ah okay yeah
yeah sorry about that uh just give me a
few more seconds this is uh
does not happen very often there we go
yeah this is the quote from the previous
one yeah I used the Anish code for this
one uh as uh he he said that the main
Intrigue is where the cost and will say
that he played well today I don't think
so and as usual Magnus whenever he plays
it extremely well even like he did here
beating Fabi like this he will probably
say that he could have done it better
but yeah in order to
fix uh what what I have done wrong I
would like to thank Benjamin Richie
Timothy Rosa and Chris Robert Picard
sapan Bhatia and Sarah Hamilton for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot and apologies for this uh see you
soon